these shadow work and pensions secretary
Jonathan Ashworth hi
um unintended consequences of free
speech if they didn't take that
particular bit out of the bill I'm not
sure that's entirely correct it looks
like they've weakened the bill or
proposing to weaken the bill I'm very
concerned about anti-semitic content
that that you can find on social media
about racist content that would be
illegal
well would it though I mean there are
concerns that what the government are
proposing Waters down the waters down
the the the
legislation and that some of this
obnoxious foul material which does
circulate social media will will still
be allowed to circulate so that there
are
I mean my other deep concern about
social media is the way it impacts on on
teenagers young people we know that
we've had absolutely tragic
consequences of young people being able
to find awful material on social media
that was admittedly that was a few years
ago but I think we have to do more to
protect our well to protect everybody
who uses social we're going to do that
to the government says by verifying ages
well I mean let's say what they're
actually proposing I know because I've
got two children I've got an 11 year old
and a nine year old I know because I've
spotted them doing it how easy it is for
them to get around to this age
verification stuff so I mean let's
actually see what they propose and if
that happens then the big media
companies the big social media companies
will have to pay up to a 10 fine for
their gross earnings well I mean that's
it I mean I just know from my own
experience as a father that my clever 11
year olds and when I say clever I don't
mean they're you know Geniuses I just
mean they know how to manipulate these
things they're able to get onto social
media I mean you know my nine-year-old I
found out and set herself up a tick tock
account when she was dancing on it so
and then she was dancing on my own Tick
Tock account and then then although In
fairness I did get a message from Tick
Tock telling me I've been suspended
because my nine-year-old had been using
my mp account to put post pictures of
herself dancing to Little Mix so
I'm now back on it if any of your
viewers want to watch me on Tick Tock
but I don't know what I'm doing do you
dance a little mix uh not on tick tock
but just to say you're an 11 year old
and your nine-year-old Daddy thinks that
you're really clever so bear that in
mind when it comes to Christmas presents
okay it's tell the whole world that
you're very clever talk to me about jobs
yeah
um what is labor gonna do about all of
these strikes that's going to [ __ ]
the country
well those strikes are a symptom of the
economic failure that we're currently
experiencing you've got 12 years of uh
low economic growth which in turn has
meant 12 years of wage squeezers that's
why workers are going on strike because
they want Fair pay settlements in the
face of this raging inflation now one of
the things that I've been I'm talking
about today is that we need to deal with
the increasing numbers of the over 50s
who have left alone market and
increasing numbers of people who are out
of work because of sickness costing up
to 8 billion over 8 billion extra a year
on the benefit Bill many of those people
say they want to go back to work and
would go back to work with the right
tailored help and support but they're
not getting it from the government
they're completely Left Behind only one
in ten disabled people and older people
are getting any help whatsoever from the
government I don't think it's good
enough to write people off I'm going to
reform the system I'm going to devolve
more power and resources to local areas
to give people the help to return to
work not if you pay nurses 17 pay rise
well the nurse is going to have to
negotiate now now this health secretary
has said oh my door is always open
that's the sort of that's a kind of
passive response the health secretary
should the Steve Barkley he should get
the nurses in and he should negotiate
them with them in good faith and I think
there is a deal to be done because in
the nurse's paper well there is I think
there's eight different pay bands that
nurses are under yeah and one of the pay
bands has I think for a different four
different bits within it so it's a very
complicated payment structure across the
different pay bands there must be a way
of doing a deal within that also the
nurses are not just striking because of
pay they're also striking because of
rotor gaps they want safe Staffing on
their Wards it's bad for patients and
their families that we have too few
nurses which is why we also need a big
plan to recruit more nurses if labor was
in power at the moment would you pay
above inflation pay Rises well if labor
was in power we would be getting the
health uh Health yeah but the point is
but when you've gone not got the money
we've got eight different pay bands and
one of the pay bands generally well
because my point is within that overall
framework I think there was a deal to be
done which deals with Fair pay but deals
with rotor gaps by giving commitments on
Recruitment and also deals with other
things like uh Child Care access
flexible working which deals that deals
with things like the support that you
get on the ward which is there's very
little of that at the moment I think a
deal could be done but Steve Barkley
needs to needs to bring the health
unions and to him to do that deal
instead just say oh my door is open and
that's a sort of passive response if we
have a strike on the Hell in the NHS
this winter we know it will be
absolutely terrible yeah of course it
will and the ball is in the government's
court if we have a strike it's their
fault for not gripping this situation
now something else that would have been
terrible and it picked up my ears when I
was watching um Sarah Jane on Sky News
yesterday afternoon we were that far
away from having problems with our
national grid during the game tonight
what's that all about well I mean this
is just tells you what happens when a
lot we've spent years now we've the
government has refused to invest
sufficiently in renewable energy sources
and we're still having this big argument
in politics or the Tory party again is
this week's Tory party argument whether
we're rounding each other how would you
fix it well well let's go for onshore
wind as one of the things we should be
doing but the Tory party are completely
arguing amongst themselves on this you
know you'll have different Tory MPS
coming on Sky News all day long you know
going at it hammering times with each
other when they should be putting the
country first so you need renewable
energy you do need to have you do need
to do more to secure your energy
supplies with set up something called
Great Britain energy as a vehicle to
invest in renewable energy for the
future because we need to become
sustainable we've seen what happens when
we're so Reliant and volatile
International Energy markets but I mean
rather party are just sort of ripping
themselves apart it's quite alarming but
thankfully um National Grid put out a
note saying that that is not going to
happen
um at least for now we'll keep an eye on
that
um who are you going to support tonight
well I'm going to spot England obviously
uh obviously uh um because I'm an
England fan okay I'm an England fan but
I mean it's it's difficult isn't it
because we do want whales to go through
as well but I mean like I I can't sort
of
so you play games I can't play games
you'd be happy for England to lose no I
wouldn't because that's game in the
system isn't it yeah it's game in the
system it's it's it's it's a difficult
one
um you know it's it you know it's a bit
like in your heels now it's a bit like
when Leicester City play wig and I want
Leicester City to win but I like wigging
to do well
today uh just before I let you go where
are we on this one love armband stuff
well the the plaque I mean I think is
ridiculous the way FIFA
um caved in like that absolutely
ridiculous I mean football doesn't
belong to FIFA it doesn't belong to
Qatar it belongs to it belongs to the
people and I think the England players
should have been allowed to wear those
armbands and um
you know
um if I had one I'd wear one but I don't
actually have one we'll get you one
um prediction for the score
oh two one
okay we'll see next time you're on oh
and who did you okay one one for I know
we're out of time
um I wanna given that I've got a
football fan on the sofa
um will we beat France
of course we will
everyone's laughing in my ear
let's see what sky used Productions Cape
early production team are laughing yeah
about the idea that England will beat
from well and Joe behind the camera as
well um
thanks a lot thank you